[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد استحواذ تقنيه ذكاء
الاصطناعي على اهتمام كبير خاصه من محبيات
تكنولوجيا لاسيما مع تردد الحديث عن انها
ستحل محل العديد من الوظائف وقد تقلل
الاعتماد على العنصر البشري مستقبلا وسط
هذا الاهتمام الكبير تظهر في كل يوم
العديد من الابحاث والدراسات التي تكشف
عيوب هذه التقنيه باحثون حذروا من امكانيه
ان يسهم روبوت شارجي في انتشار الاخبار
والمعلومات الزائفه ووفقا لتقرير نظرته
جامعه جورج تاون ومصدر للانترنت فان تشارت
سوف يسهل عمليه نشر المعلومات الخاطئه على
الانترنت وقال التقرير ان تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي تطورت بشكل كبير ما يسهم في
انتاج محتوى متنوع لكنها في نفس الوقت قد
تحمل اثارا سلبيه عبر انتاج معلومات زائفه
تاثير على الراي العامه ويحتوي نموذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي على مجموعه بيانات كبيره
جدا من النصوص وما يفعله النظام هو انه
يواصل كتابه ما يتضمنه من بياناته ويمكن
ان يجري حوارا مثلا والاجابه على الاسئله
كذلك وتحديد الاخطاء بحثون حذروا من قدرته
على الاحتيال حتى على المجامع العلميه
وعلى الباحثين حيث استطاع تمرير ابحاث
اجتازت عمليه كشف الاحتيال وحصلت على
درجات تقييم عاليه ما يجعل مستقبل البشريه
برمتها في خطر
[موسيقى]
تقنيه تم طرحها للاستخدام المجاني في
نوفمبر الماضي طورتها شركه ابحاث الذكاء
الاصطناعي open اي اي الامريكيه عباره عن
روبوت او برنامج ذكاء اصطناعي يستطيع
الاجابه على ما يطرح عليه من اسئله بشكل
تفصيلي ودقيق يمكنه كتابه موضوعات صحفيه
كامله اعتمادا على ما يقدمه المستخدم
للمدخلات يمكن لتشات جي بي تي ان تستخدم
في التسويق الالكتروني وتطوير المحتوى عبر
انترنت وخدمه العملاء او المساعده في
تصحيح الاخطاء البرمجيه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من جدي عبر
سكايب عادل الغامدي الباحث في تقنيه
المعلومات والنظم الامنيه اهلا بك من دبي
عبر زوم انس المرعي المتخصص في الشؤون
المعلوماتيه وتقنيه اهلا بكمين اسمح لي ان
ابدا من جده معك استاذ عادل استاذ عادل
اسمح لي ان ابدا بتغريده ايلون ماسك في
هذا الاطار هو وصف تشارجي وقال بانه
جيد بشكل مخيف سؤال مطروح مع كل ما ذكرناه
من تفاصيل من ايجابيات ومن سلبيات هل يمكن
اعتبار هذا
هل يمكن اعتبار تشارديو مخيف ام هو جيد
وقادر ان يضيف على عالمنا على قدراتنا
اهلا وسهلا مساء الخير للجميع هو بالفعل
نحن نتكلم هي شركه جديده
عمرها اشهر بدت
اول نزوله كان تقريبا في نوفمبر 2022
وبدات التجارب عليه الناس عندها التباس
ايشات ايش الفرق بين شات جي بي تي وجوجل
لما نيجي نتكلم على جوجل مثلا انت لما شخص
يبحث عن وصفه معينه او استخدام علاج معين
في جوجل بيكتب الجرعه المناسبه لعلاج
الفلاني حيبدا يطلع لك جوجل عده خيارات
عده احتمالات او عده مواضيع تتكلم في
النقطه هذه
حياخذ نفس كلماتك وحيرد عليها الجرعه
المناسبه لعلاج الفلاني ان تكون كذا ويبدا
يتكلم لك زي ما كانها وصفه طبيه يتناقش
معاك نقاش مباشر
ما الذي يضمن لي بان ما يقوله تشارجي هو
صحيح لان جوجل يعطيني خيارات وانا
بمنطقي ببحوثه يعني
البحث اللي اقوم به يمكن ان اميز بين
الاخبار الزائفه من عدمها ولكن بهذه
المنصه الجديده هي تضعني امام امر واقع
صحيح جوجل بيعطي لك عده خيارات بيعطي لك
مواقع بيعطيلك جهات حكوميه بيعطيلك
مستشفيات بيعطيلك مراكز ابحاث شات تتكلم
معاه مباشره بيرد عليك مباشره وعنده قاعده
بيانات حيعتمد عليها فقاعده البيانات اللي
بيعتمد عليها هي مجموعه معلومات هيعمل
اجاباته ما بيخش بيعمل بحوث في مواقع
ويجيب لك اجابات عليها
احنا لما نيجي نطالع في السابق اول بدايه
جوجل قبل قبل قبل ما يظهر جوجل كان كل
الناس بتستخدم مواقع البحث قاعد تستخدم
ياهو تستخدم مايكروسوفت تستخدم موقع اسمه
هذا الموقع كانت تستخدمها بمجرد ان ظهور
جوجل وبدا ينشر وبدا ينتشر بدا يخش على
المواقع وينسخ البيانات اللي فيها عمل
الصعود جوجل
ايش اللي حيعمله كيف حيتطور هنا الوضع
مخيف هل ممكن الشخص يغذي بمعلومات خاطئه
هل ممكن الشخص
بافكار متناقضه تعمدت عده اختبارات عليه
بلوغات مختلفه تخرج
بعض الاوقات
فالبرنامج جديد يقوم بانه ترجمته
لا تعادل حتى مستوى ترجمه جوجل ولكن خليني
اسال الاستاذ انس في هذا الاطار استاذ انس
هل موضوع مخيف يعني ايلون ماسك قال مخيف
ضيفي كذلك من جداله استاذ عادل اعتبر بان
هناك مخاوف تحوم حول هذه التقنيه الجديده
حضرتك هل تعتقد بان السلبيات اقوى من
الايجابيات ام العكس
مساء الخير يا ملكنا الاستاذ عادل ولجميع
المشاهدين
خلينا نقول هو تكنولوجيا مثل مثل اي
تكنولوجيا له
ثوره خلينا نقول في البدايه وهو مثله مثل
اي اداه في العالم سواء القلم العادي او
الادوات الرقميه اللي بدي اقوله هون انه
القلم ممكن
ثوره والثورات ليس بالاكيد تاتي بامور
ايجابيه
يعني الثوره يعني تفتح افق يعني تبقى
مجهوله في بعض الاحيان في الكثير من
الاحيان
تجربه شخصيه في الشركه التي اعمل فيها
شركه تسويق رقمي
الحقيقه تم استبدال اشخاص في المؤسسه
بعض الاشخاص
باستخدام املاشات صار عنده القدره على انه
ينتج عن اربع خمس زملاء وبالتالي البقاء
للاقوى
وتم استبدال هذه الاشخاص
بقوه تشان هل هناك اخطاء اول ما تعملي
تسجيل في تشاد بحذرك بانه هو ليس
بالكامل وجميع التكنولوجيا كل التكنولوجيا
في العالم بعيده كليا عن التمام والكمال
لكن نحن بننظر للجانب الايجابي وايضا
بناخذ بعين الاعتبار الجانب السلبي
والجانب اللا اخلاقي للذكاء الاصطناعي ليس
فقط لايجاد جي بي تي كاداء لوحده
سيد عادل
ضيفي يطرح نقطه في الواقع طرحت اول ما بدا
المتابع تلفته مثل هكذا اخبار عن وهي هل
يمكن لهذه المنصه ان تعوض
البشر ان تعوض الموظف او الموظف والى اي
مدى هذا قادر ان يكون نحن تبعنا روبوتات
قادره ولكن ليس بهذا الشكل بهذا المستوى
الذي تقدمه
نقدر نقول الثوره او الجيل الثالث في
التقنيه التخاطب
رسائل بعدين الماسنجر بعدين دخل الواتساب
اللي بعمل اجابات الاليه لاغلب الشركات
استخدمت الواتساب بحيث انك ترسل رساله
بيرد عليك ويبدا في تواصل بتبدا تعمل طلب
تبغى تعمل تسجيل
فالناس كانت متضايقه منها جدا زي ما يقول
المثل حافظ مش فاهم
الشات جي بي تي قاعد قاعد يعكس المعادله
هذه
هو التقنيه ما حد حيقدر يوقف قدامها
التقنيه متطوره اذا انت بتتركها حتلاقي
نفسك متخلف عن العالم لكن المشكله الخوف
الرئيسي انه هي قواعد بيانات هي معلومات
لمن انت تحط البرنامج كمنشاه خاصه انت
قاعد تديره كشخص انت هتوجه توجيهاتك لانه
بعض المنشات هي بتوجه الشات حسب قواعد
بياناتها حسب طلباتها هي لكن مش كل الناس
عندما التوجه هذا في ناس اكيد بتصير
استخدام التقنيه احنا الخوف دائما نتكلم
عن سوء استخدام التقنيات كثير شفنا في عده
مواقع ما في انظمه دوليه تحكم كل الدوله
بيقول لك لا احنا التويتر بيصير عليه
مخالفات عاليه جدا وبيقول لك لا هذه حريه
هذه حريه خطاب هذه حريه في التعبير فيسبوك
حريه في التعبير تويتر حريه في التعبير
شات جي بي تي ايش يقول بكره الشخص حيجي
يتكلم معاك كيف اعمل كيف اعمل مخدرات كيف
اقوم بعمليه جريمه قتل وما حد يعرفني كيف
الهدف انه اغلب
صحيح صحيح وربما هذه نقاط هي متوفره على
جوجل لكن ابعد من ذلك وهنا سؤال لك سيده
انس ضيفي يتحدث عن مخاوف والبعض يتحدث حتى
ليس عن مخاوف ولكن عن صعوبه في فرض مثل
هكذا تقنيات في عالمنا الحديث بمعنى انت
تعلم سيد انس بانه هناك مؤسسات مثلا
تستعمل الروبوتات الاليه
للاجابه لما تتصل ببنك او تتصل بمؤسسه
يجيبك الروبوت هي تسهل ماموريه المؤسسه
ولكن تصعب في بعض الاوقات علينا لانه
الروبوت ليس في كل الاحوال يفهمنا ويفهم
مطالبنا وبالتالي اضافه تقنيه اخرى ويمكن
توسيع نطاق عملها هل يضعن امام صعوبات
اضافيه
خليني يعني اقسم سؤالك ابدا من القسم
الاخير في السؤال نعم نتصل في البنوك او
في المؤسسات برد علينا
[موسيقى]
هل هو يعني كاد ينافس الانسان بالطبع لا
هل هي التكنولوجيا في بدايتها نعم هل
التطور موجود وقادم في المستقبل نعم وبشكل
كبير
القسم الثاني اللي بدي احكي لك اياه هو
مشاركه هذا الموضوع في الاقتصاد خليني
اعطيك شويه تحديثات صارت في الاقتصاد
الخليجي وتحديدا في مثلا في دوله الامارات
عنا برنامج استراتيجي للذكاء الصناعي
اليوم
الناتج المحلي الاماراتي من
العالم الرقمي او من الاقتصاد الرقمي 11.7
وفي هدف يصير 20% من هون
لثلاثين اقر وزير التربيه والتعليم
الاماراتي في
القمه العالميه للحكومات بان هناك راح
يكون معلم ذكي اي اي والنقطه الثانيه ايضا
راح يكون ضمن المناهج التدريسيه للطلبه في
المدارس
لتقليل الجاب او الفراغ بين الواقع وبين
سوق العمل تتذكروا نحن زمان مثلا كان
نمنع من استخدام الاله الحاسبه بينما لما
طلعنا للعالم الواقعي كانت الاله الحاسبه
موجوده عند الكل ومتوفره وقيادات
نفس نفس الشيء تقريبا يعني لو انا بدي
ارجع اقارن 30 سنه من التكنولوجيا اللي عم
بيصير في اليوم نفس الشيء المضحك اني
الان سالت شات جي بي تي ونحن عم نتحدث وعم
نسمع للدكتور للاستاذ عادل سالته هل انت
مظلل قال لي انا لست مضلل كوني نموذج لغوي
ذكي وظيفتي تقديمه المعلومه على الاسئله
التي يطرحها
[ضحك]
بسرعه ما راح اطير ويقول ولكن يجب على
المستخدمين انتهى تماما توقيه اعذرني انس
المرعي شكرا لك وعادل الغامدي شكرا جزيلا
لكما والحديث دائما بقي السلام عليكم